thank you for being here let us go
through some updates for today so
everyone knows where we are and what
we're experiencing as you can see the
increase on the trajectory of cases
continues to climb 76 81 a couple of
updates that I would like to make to the
local health providers we want to
anticipate this situation we talked
yesterday about planning forward getting
ahead of it that we have been behind on
this virus from day one and rather than
be reactive be proactive get ahead of it
local health providers should be
watching what's going on in different
parts of the state and anticipating
what's going to happen this is going to
be a phenomenon of a rolling apex we
keep talking about the apex the top of
the curve but the top of the curve will
occur at different times in different
places right the curve is a function of
the rate of spread the rate of density
and when it started so you'll see
different curves you see it all across
the country started in Washington state
of Washington now you see New York you
see Chicago you see New Orleans you see
parts of California so that rolling apex
is happening across the country that
rolling apex is also going to be
happening across the state of New York
the current projections all say New York
City will face the first high-water mark
if you will high tide mark the high
height of the curve but then you'll see
Westchester you'll see Long Island on a
delay with their curve hitting a new
height model projectors are not sure if
it's Westchester first or long Long
Island first some suggest it's
Westchester because we had that cluster
in Westchester if you remember at New
Rochelle
and then upstate New York we expect a
curve in upstate New York also may not
be as high obviously as New York City
Westchester Long Island but there will
be a curve so if you are not in a highly
affected health area now that doesn't
mean you're not going to have a real
situation to deal with because these
numbers are just going to continue to go
up all across the state so for a local
health system this is a new challenge
most health systems have public
hospitals and then they have private
hospitals or volunteer voluntary
hospitals and they basically exist on a
day to day basis as to different systems
so you'll have public hospitals and then
you have the private hospital system and
for all intensive purposes in normal
operating procedures they operate as two
systems this very little interaction
there's also very little interaction
among individual hospitals sometimes
even within the Oh their own system so
you have public hospitals that are part
of a public hospital system but each
Hospital basically operates on its own
right has its own identity certainly
true on the private side where you have
individual hospitals and they operate on
their own we have to change that
mentality and we have to change that
mentality quickly no hospital is an
island no hospital in this situation can
exist unto its unto themselves we really
have to have a new mentality a new
culture of hospitals working with one
another both within the public system as
well as the private system and we need
to think about the public system working
with the private system in a way they
never have before
there is an artificial wall almost
between those two systems right now
that that wall has to come down that
theory has to come down this is going to
be all hands on deck this is everybody
helping everyone else one hospital gets
overwhelmed the other hospitals have to
have to flex to help that hospital and
vice versa the we have Elmhurst Hospital
for example in New York City that is
under stress the number of cases in the
Elmhurst Hospital is high when the
number of cases is high the stress on
the staff is high I was just being with
dr. Zucker about this you do this for
two three four weeks the level of stress
is very intense Elmhurst Hospital is
part of a public health system of about
11 hospitals in New York City that
system has to work together and those
hospitals have to work together the 11
health and hospital in New York City the
public system and I'm going to ask mayor
de Blasio and controller stringer to
take a look at the system and figure out
how we can get that system to work
better together as a unified system this
is not going to get better soon right so
Elmhurst is under stress now that stress
does not abate for this foreseeable
short-term future so how do we make that
system work better together and what
recommendations do we have to improve
HNH we'll also be meeting with the
private hospitals in New York City that
are organized through something called
the Greater New York Hospital
Association I'm going to be meeting with
them tomorrow to talk about having those
hospitals also organized act as one get
out of their silos get out of their
identities to work together and then
overall you have these local health
systems
the state's role which we've never
really done before is getting those
health systems to work with one another
so we talked about if New York City gets
overwhelmed we'll ask the Upstate
systems to be a relief valve for the
downstate health systems which has never
happened before to any school and also
vice versa there will be a time where
the Upstate hospitals will be struggling
and when the Upstate hospitals will be
struggling then we want the downstate
hospitals to be able to take over and
relieve those hospitals that's actually
the advantage of the rolling curve that
they're projecting if it does happen
that way
theoretically that the I almost think of
it as a high tide mark right high tide
comes first in New York City then the
tide is on the way down and then it's
high tide in upstate New York okay so if
it's if the tide is dropping downstate
then you have some relief for the
upstate hospitals we put in place the
New York pause program today I am going
to extend it to April 15th the directive
that non-essential State Workforce
continue to work from home we're doing
it in two week intervals because every
day is a new day and we'll see what
happens day to day but I think it's not
even questionable today but that we're
going to need two more weeks of
non-essential workers good news
wodsworth has developed a New York State
Department of Health has developed a
less intrusive saliva and short nasal
swab test I'm not exactly sure what a
short nasal swab test is but my guess is
it wouldn't apply to me it can be
administered in the presence of health
care workers it requires less PPE health
care workers can self administer it so
kudos to the Department of Health on
that
it also helps them as limit exposure for
healthcare workers and it should start
as soon as next week people ask when is
this over
I think the testing you tell me when
they come up with a an inexpensive home
test or a point-of-care test that can be
brought to volume I think that's
probably when you see a real return to
normalcy in the workforce in other words
we're all talking about this curve
flatten the curve what at what point on
the other side of the curve do you go
back to work Jessie asked this question
the other day there is no answer I think
the answer is going to be in testing dr.
pouchy who I think is is we're so
blessed to have him here at this time he
talks about faster easier testing if you
can test millions of people if you could
test today millions of people you could
send them to work tomorrow right so the
development of these tests I think are
very important instructive tomorrow the
USNS comfort is coming that is about
1,000 bed capacity it's staffed by
federal officials federal medical
professionals
it is not for covered patients but it is
to take the backfill from hospitals
current stockpile was still working to
purchase and equipment all across the
globe we have a whole team that's
working seven days a week unfortunately
we're competing against every other
state in the United States for these
same things so it's it's very hard but
we're making progress in terms of
finding staff that's going very well the
volunteerism of New Yorkers god bless
them we're up to 76 thousand health care
workers who are volunteered 76,000
76,000 people who volunteer to go into
these hospitals at this time
just think about that on the total
people tested we did 16,000 last night
total of 170 mm tested that's the
highest in the state highest in the
country I'm sorry positive cases 7,000
last night total cases 59,000 the virus
continues its march across the state of
New York only two counties now that
don't have cases these are the overall
numbers fifty nine thousand people
tested positive eight thousand currently
hospitalized two thousand ICU patients
3,500 patients discharged we know but we
nobody really points to these numbers
but this is good news 846 people came
out of hospitals yesterday discharged
after being treated for cold right so
yes people get it 80% have either self
resolved or have some symptoms at home
20% going to the hospital majority of
those get treated and leave it's the
acutely ill by and large who are the
vulnerable population and that's what
we're seeing more and more the deaths
went from 728 to 965 what's happening
now is as I mentioned yesterday people
are on the on the ventilator longer and
longer the longer you are on a
ventilator unless your chance of ever
getting off that ventilator and that's
what we're seeing and we will continue
to see the number of deaths increase in
terms of most impacted States again New
York is still number one total new
hospitalizations these are the charts we
look at every night the numbers up 1175
it was 847 the night before these
bounced night tonight
anyone night's data
could have a number of variables in it
what what hospitals actually reported
when they reported it how accurate they
were so more you look for a trendline
more than anything else and there are
trend lines if you look on the
hospital's hospitalization rate was
doubling every two days then it doubled
every three days then it doubled every
four days now it's doubling every six
days so you have almost a dichotomy the
doubling rate is slowing and that is
good news but the number of cases are
still going up so you're still going up
towards an apex but the rate of the
doubling is slowly which is good news
changing daily ICU admissions you see a
tick up in the ICU admissions but again
you see the you look for the trend line
among those columns more than the
individual columns change in daily
intubations we don't normally run this
chart but these are the people who are
most seriously affected and again you
see a trend line in that you see some
aberrations March 26 the 290 but you see
a trend line and the trend line is what
we're watching you also see a trend line
in people being discharged okay and this
is a dramatic trend line so people came
in they started to get treated only
March 18th right so we're only talking
about ten days they started to get
treated a few of them got out early
a few more a few more a few more a few
more and now you're seeing the discharge
number trend way up because that's
what's going to happen people go into
the hospital they get treated they leave
those that are acutely ill get put on a
ventilator and then it's the the inverse
dynamic the longer they're on the
intimate into beta the longer they are
intubated the longer they are on the
ventilator the higher the mortality rate
again perspective these are the numbers
from day one since China started also we
should all keep in mind we lost the
first responders who go out there I was
talking about the 76,000 people who
volunteered to help medical
professionals being a first responder
today being a public health official
working in a hospital working with
senior citizens this is really an act of
love and courage
we lost detective Cedric Nelson Nick
Dixon 48 years old thirty second 23-year
veteran could have retired so we wish
him and his family peace we lost a nurse
we've lost a couple of other nurses
Carlos Kelly 48 years old who was the
assistant nurse manager at Mount Sinai
West we wish his family the best these
public people I I don't even have the
words to express my admiration for them
FDR always had words courage is not the
absence of fear but rather the
assessment that something else is more
important than fear to me that says it
all today everyone is afraid everyone is
afraid you think these police officers
are not afraid to leave their house you
think these nurses are not afraid to go
into the hospital
they're afraid but something is more
important than their fear which is their
passion their commitment for public
service and helping others that's all it
is it's just their passion and belief in
helping others and that overcomes their
fear and that makes them in my book just
truly amazing outside
ending human beings and I wish them and
their families all the best the
president and the CD order is a CDC
ordered a travel advisory for people of
New York New Jersey and Connecticut this
happened last night this is not a
lockdown it is a travel advisory to be
implemented by the states in essence
it's nothing that we haven't been doing
right non-essential people should stay
at home so it's totally consistent with
everything we're doing and I support
what the president did because it
affirms what we've been doing it also
firms what new your New Jersey and
Connecticut have been doing Rhode Island
issued an executive order that New York
license plates would be theoretically
stopped at the border for mandatory
quarantine of some period that executive
order has been repealed by the state of
Rhode Island and we thank them for their
cooperation that was repealed last night
personal opinion not fact
gratuitous this is disorienting it's
frightening
it's disturbing your whole life is
turned upside down overnight do the best
you can you find a way to create some
joy you try you try to find a silver
lining and all of this how do you break
up the monotony what do you do how do
you bring a smile to people's face give
you my idea for today Sunday I come from
an Italian American family sunday was
family day we had the big family dinner
would you'd have liked in the afternoon
so it was a confusing but it was like a
lunch late lunch they called dinner and
it was spaghetti and meatballs and
sausages and
my family would all get together and it
was a beautiful time I didn't really
appreciate it as a kid but it was just
beautiful because they all came together
and the grandparents were there and they
would start to eat it 2 o'clock there
was like a marathon session the food was
really just the attraction to get people
together you know everybody talks about
how the Italians love the food
that's true but really they they loved
bringing the family together and the
food was the the way that people came
together and then you sat at the table
and it was just a two three-hour affair
my mother and father did it all so not
to the same extent my grandparents did
it but we had that same Sunday dinner
around the table I tried to continue it
as a father with my kids I was divorced
and so I'm not really the best cook to
say the least but we would have on
Sundays I would actually go to the
Italian specialty store and I would buy
the meatballs and buy the sausages and
buy the sauce but I would put it in a
pot and I would put it on the stove and
because part of it was that sauce would
sit there all day and it was just simmer
you know and you'd smell it all through
the house and then I'd make them sit
down and we would have spaghetti and
meatballs and sausage on Sundays and my
daughter Cara's in the back the they
would never eat the sausage and the
meatballs they would pick at the pasta
because they they they knew I didn't
know how to cook so they knew that
meatball and sausage was inherently
suspect and I never said that I bought
it in the specialty store because that
would have ruined the whole tradition
anyway so they wouldn't need it and we
go to we'd go for Chinese food
afterwards but the that that convening
was something special and today we're
going to have
our family dinner we're missing one
daughter Mariah we're gonna get Mariah
on skype and grandma's gonna be on the
telephone and we're gonna sit around the
table and we're going to have that kind
of coming together a little different
Skype telephones but you know what with
everything going on family we're here
we're together we're healthy that's 98%
of it so find ways to make a little joy
also for new yorkers i know we feel
under attack i had a lot of phone calls
yesterday when the president first
suggested some form of quarantine what
does that mean quarantine am i going to
be allowed to leave the house my parents
who are supposed to be coming back and
this one's here and this one's here i
know we feel under attack the rhode
island
you can't drive into rhode island will
pull you over with the police yes New
York is the epicenter and these are
different times and many people are
frightened some of the reactions you get
from individuals even from governments
are frightening and suggesting that
they're they'll take abrupt actions
against New York but look this is New
York and we are going to make it through
this we have made it through far greater
things we are going to be okay we
specialized in stamina and strength and
instability and that's just what we're
doing now we are strong we have
endurance and we have stability and we
know what we're doing we have a plan
we're executing the plan anything any
obstacle that we come across
we will manage that obstacle and we have
I can't sit here and say to anyone
you're not going to see people pass away
you will that is the nature of what
we're dealing with and that's beyond any
of our control but New York is going to
have what it needs and no one is going
to attack New York unfairly and no one
is going to deprive New York of what it
needs that's why I'm here that's why we
have a state full of very talented
professional people so a deep breath on
all of that and we are doing exactly
what we need to do there is no state in
the nation that is better prepared or
better mobilized than what we're doing
and I feel that deeply and having
studied everything that every other
state has done federal officials have
even remarked to me that they're
surprised how quickly a state is big and
complicated as New York has actually
mobilized so feel good about that there
are two great New York expressions that
I use all the time anything I build in
New York always has two expressions on
it one Excelsior says that all ever
upwards ever upwards aspirational we can
be better we will be better we're going
to aim higher we're going to improve
ourselves excelsior state model it's on
the seal behind me Excelsior and the
other EEP Laura Basu
out of many one unity unity you put
those two things together it says it all
aim high do better believe you can do
better be optimistic and the way you get
there is through unity and togetherness
and cooperation and through mutuality
and community those two expressions I
say to my daughters if you remember
nothing else when I'm gone if you walk
up to the box and have nothing else to
remember excelsior you can be better it
will be better we can make it better
eeep lure of a pseudonym we make it
better together that's it and that's
what we're doing questions when are we
running patients into Javitz jabots will
be coming online this week also remember
a lot of what we're doing is we're
building capacity and assembling
supplies for the apex you get these
people say well you don't need this
today yeah I know I don't need it today
because I know where we are on the
trajectory today I have to prepare for
the apex for the curve that's where I
need the beds that's where I need the
supplies etc that's when I say get ahead
of this thing right the virus has been
ahead of us I want to get ahead of the
virus I want to get to that apex before
the virus gets to the apex so the Javits
is part of that supply but it will be
coming on online this week when we
actually utilize it is when we need it
it's hard it's hard but on the flip side
I say look at what happened in New
Rochelle those gatherings that brought
people together were religious
gatherings and brought hundreds of
people together which was beautiful but
it made many many people ill and density
is the enemy here for this
/ -
time so you worship worship the way you
can but the gatherings are just not a
good idea by the way the patient zero
what we call patient zero in Westchester
New Rochelle who was very sick for a
very long time he has actually gone home
am I correct
I spoke to the governor of Rhode Island
yesterday and we had a conversation I
don't think the order was called for I
don't believe it was legal
I don't believe was neighborly I
understood the point but I thought there
were different ways to do it and the
governor of Rhode Island was very
receptive and I thank her very much for
reconsidering her position 237 deaths in
the last 24 hours in the state of New
York
222 it seems in New York City what are
your projections showing in terms of
what this apex might look like in terms
of fatalities are we talking hundreds of
people thousands of people what what are
you seeing inside
Jim Howard do you know I'm sure so you
know there's many different projections
that were working at and it does see
that will be already we're at 965 and so
we do see in the thousands but again
these are models and and and we have to
plan for what the model may show but
hopefully you'll be less New Yorkers are
we talking hundreds of deaths a day
thousands of deaths a day it goes back
to the the the numbers we've always said
that 80% of individuals get better and
we've said that of the other 20% some
end up in the hospital and it's a small
percentage that end up unfortunately
dying and that percentage as we're
looking at the numbers is actually
hovering around one or even less than 1%
so again it's determined by how many
people are positive opinion jesse not
data-driven
I don't see how you look at those
numbers and conclude anything less than
thousands of people will pass away
because remember who it's attacking it's
attacking the vulnerable underlying
illness etc and I don't see how you get
past that curve without seeing thousands
of people pass away
I hope it's wrong nursing homes are
about 1/4 of the coronavirus deaths
frankly I'm I'm we are lucky that it's
only 1/4 coronavirus and a nursing home
is a toxic mix we've said that from day
one we saw that in Washington State this
virus preys on the vulnerable it preys
on seniors it preys on people with
compromised immune systems and
underlying illnesses and coronavirus in
a nursing home can be like fire through
dry grass the state has put in different
precautions we're not even allowing
visitors into nursing homes now which is
really harsh frankly unless the person
there unless what we call there are
exigent circumstances where the person
is in a desperate situation and then the
family comes in to see them the staff is
being tested before they go in so we're
doing everything we can but this is a
truly terrible virus to stop and that
combination is Lisa coronavirus in a
nursing home is lethal the only question
is how many people will die
yes okay and then to go back to the
point that dr. Zucker who's making
obviously we're testing in a very large
race that was getting a lot of more
positives
maybe compared to other jurisdictions so
what numbers are you actually the rate
of ICU intubation you look at all the
numbers we look at all of this so we
look at the trends it's very important
look at the trends as the governor
mentioned that is a it is a trend that
we need to follow whether it's
intubations ICU care and obviously we
look at the case fatality rate which is
the number of people have died which is
the number over the larger number of
people have tested New York has tested
many people more than anyone else
yeah Jimmy if I can on that the question
was basically what numbers do you look
at to make a projection as dr. sacra
said you look at all of them but I would
not look at the testing numbers I
wouldn't overweight the testing numbers
because the testing numbers are not
random the testing numbers are all self
selected right these are people who
you're testing because they're suspect
of being positive and we don't do the
projections ourselves we have Columbia
Weill Medical Center that does
projections the CDC does projections we
have McKinsey company that we hired to
do projections so there are a number of
firms that do these projection models
and they go back to studying China and
South Korea and everything else and they
have models the models some of the
models are all over the place right so
we we do the best we can to pick a
reasonable model not the highest not the
lowest a reasonable model plan for that
model plan for that apex that's where we
got from day one 140,000 hospital beds
40,000 ICU beds that's from that model
at the apex at the apex well you don't
need 140,000 hospital beds today
course not we need them at the apex but
that's where we got those original
projections then you have actuality
right which is when you're pointing to
you can see the day to day how many come
in how many go out the discharge rate
the death rate and that's what we're
plotting and then they take every day
and they put it against their projection
but you still only have a projection
they still can't tell you they're
watching at this they're watching for
the slowing of the number of cases and
when you see the number of cases the
increase in the number of cases slowing
then you are theoretically reaching the
apex and otherwise you just watch it day
to day I did not hear that Jimmy I don't
know what Florida did but I will look
into it
two parts take this take first and
second questions doctor you want to come
at them or Jim you want talk about the
mental health program we have a
volunteer program we have nearly 12,000
mental health experts and professionals
who have signed up to offer services to
New Yorkers either by a telephone or
skype or other things so that program is
going quite well of psychologists and
psychiatrists that are mental health
experts to help with that we are
tracking criminal justice
expecting to do something that's more
many of the people while people are
skyping because we want to limit its
distance we want people to distance from
one another now so many of those
volunteers that I mentioned are actually
New Yorkers who are just giving their
time and expertise to help New Yorkers
in need right now it's very New York
Century yup that's right it's tough to
tell how its emerging we have seen
there's some antidotal instances of
increased of domestic violence issues
and the Department of Health and other
government agencies have been monitoring
and trying to provide services where
where possible but I would defer to dr.
Zechariah we as Jim said we're working
with all the different agencies across
the state on this issue of some mental
health and all the other agencies and
I've also reached out to some of the
professionals in the private sector to
ask some of the recommendations they may
have sir I appreciate it could you
please speak to there was ample warning
before coronavirus touched on on maybe
ruptures that there should be large mass
gathering should be banned all gathering
should be banned there should be large
workplace restrictions
why didn't you shut down the state
sooner I think we shut it down I think
we were one of the first to shut it down
you know shutting it down is not without
criticism either right you're trying to
balance this you now have the
conversation about when do you bring the
economy back right when you open it up
shutting it down is a very drastic
measure but I think we were one of the
first also you want to do it in a way
that doesn't create more fear and more
panic you're fighting two things we're
still fighting two things last night we
were fighting two things you're fighting
the virus and you're fighting the fear I
can't
tell you how many people called all
night long about the mandatory
quarantine comment that the president
made as he was getting into a helicopter
which was inconclusive by the way even
if you've heard his comment he didn't
was not conclusive in his comment but
people are so on edge I mean it really
panicked people they were going to leave
the city last night it was really so you
need to manage that fear in the panic
and you also need to do with the virus
we were one of the first I never used
the term shelter in place because I
believe that was an inflammatory term
and incorrect by the way they still use
it nobody has a shelter in place policy
shelter in place was from the nuclear
war threat go to a room in the middle of
your home that has no windows stay there
until they give you the all-clear sign
what modern times it was for an active
shooter concept or in schools that's not
what this was but you say that nuclear
war active shooter you know so it's how
you do it but we were one of the first
to do it such a quick flip now do you
regret not you know placing more
restrictions sooner closing States I
think we were the most dramatic
basically the first point front line
first responders have the virus and
tested positive are you hearing from
hospitals and other folks I don't have
we don't have a statistic on how many
first responders specifically proved
positive
Medicaid funding for New Yorkers because
you're not willing to delay the Medicaid
reforms until the federal funding runs
out especially at this time yes well I
say to Senator Schumer be nice if he
passed a piece of legislation that
actually helped the state of New York
the piece of legislation he passed
stopped the state from a process that
was happening for six months which was
redesigning the Medicaid program to make
it more efficient and more effective it
was called the Medicaid redesign team I
announced it back in January it's the
second time we did it and it takes waste
and fraud and inefficiency out of the
system and that was going on since
January the legislation he passed said
you can't redesign Medicaid for what
reason I have no idea so it disqualified
this state from funding and he knew that
when he passed it because yeah I have no
choice because on the know I'll tell you
two and a half billion per year
recurring is worth more than six billion
one shot I'd rather have 2.5 2.5 2.5
then 6 billion today and I called every
congressional representative and told
them why would you want to stop a
Medicaid redesign that's been going on
since January I don't know what their
political calculus was but that's all it
was was a political calculus there's no
good government reason to say why you
would want
stopped a Medicaid redesign headed by
Dennis Rivera former head of $11.99
Michael Dowling top health care
professional in the state passed by the
assembly and the Senate a state passed
Medicaid redesign effort why would you
ever want to stop that I don't know
whose politics they're playing but they
didn't represent the people in state one
of the numbers are important the six
billion dollar number we can't get to
this experiment number no matter how us
to make those numbers it's probably
closer to about four billion dollars and
that assumes that the emergency is in
place for a full year there's nothing in
that in that bill that says that it will
last for a year in fact it will end as
soon as the president declares the
emergency is over so that could happen
at any time
so that four billion dollar number also
is reduced if it's half a year it's to
then a significant portion of that money
doesn't come to the state it went to
local governments so you're left with a
number that's under two billion dollars
potentially if at most
which then you're basically saying take
a one-shot of these funds don't reform
the Medicaid system and spend that money
inefficiently on a system that
unanimously everyone on there
understood was not working properly with
wasting the money so the choices really
wastes the money that way or do a bill
that actually provides funding to New
York State that bill doesn't even give
us a fraction of the amount of money
that is needed for the budget but just
to so you have a fact it's two billion
take two billion for sure right door a
door be take door a a two billion for
sure or door B for 2.6 billion I pick
the door with 2.6 billion not because I
like to let it be but I think
2.6 billion the real question is to me
Jimmy why would you do that to the state
of New York
why would you say stop a Medicaid
redesign that saves taxpayers money that
has to be passed by the assembly and has
to be passed by the Senate why would a
federal government say I'm going to
trample the states right to redesign its
Medicaid program that it runs that saves
money what what is I don't even know
what the political interest is they're
trying to protect but two billion versus
2.6 I picked 2.6 second the problem with
the budget is the numbers why because
the federal government what we just
talked about was in the previous bill
two bills ago the bill that just passed
we get 1.9 percent of our state budget
about 5 billion dollars which is 1.9
percent of our budget only to use for
coronavirus expenses okay five billion
dollars 1.9 percent of our budget only
for coronavirus expenses first point you
have states that got 10% of their budget
20 percent of their budget in
coronavirus expenses that don't even
have coronavirus cases you have some
states have four cases we have more
cases than anyone else we got the lowest
level of reimbursement in the bill what
happened to funding need second the
federal bill had no funding for the fact
that states have lost revenue and
speaker Pelosi god bless her was asked
today
how about Governor Cuomo's point that it
didn't do anything to help the state
and the speaker basically said yeah we
have to come back and pass another bill
so we have a ten billion dollar 15
billion dollar revenue hole that the
federal government did nothing to help
on now I have to do is stay budget so
now I say the state is simply in state
Senate by the way we have a ten or
fifteen billion dollar hole they don't
want to hear it
right nobody wants to hear it I don't
want hear it unfortunately I have to
live with it but how do you do a budget
with that big a hole and remember the
great heartbreak was we were all waiting
for this last federal piece of
legislation because we all believed it
was going to have money to help us with
our revenue shortfall and then it didn't
so like that shock was just two or three
days ago now we have to do the budget
next week the help we were waiting for
from Washington never came now we have
to make drastic cuts to the budget like
you have never seen the travel advisory
how do you envision non-essential travel
I mean business travel for many people
is considered essential you yourself
said that the financial sector is
important how do you imagine that and
are you asking people not to come to New
York to do business
no saying definitions is we have Jesse
non-essential if you are non-essential
worker you shouldn't be leaving your
home if you are essential worker then
you can take a bus a train a car or
plane so should people be traveling to
new same rules if they are essential
business travelers yes looks like you
could still find
without shifting costs to counties and
what would be the impact of the
across-the-board cuts that the meta
marty is looking at there that are you
know possible at a time of a public
health crisis well we we do have funding
the question is how do we fund the
healthcare cost the federal government
did provide healthcare funded I have
five billion dollars in the bill for
coronavirus funding but you know every
hospital now has coronavirus expenses so
we have five billion dollars for
healthcare in hospitals there pranic Lee
our last problem in some ways is the
healthcare budget because we've received
five billion dollars and the hospitals
have received a lot of money the big
problem is how do you fund the schools
because the schools are the second big
expenses for the state after healthcare
and that's where we have zero dollars
couldn't we do short short-term
borrowing yeah the issue is right we're
not gonna have revenue in the first
quarter of this year as a result of the
delay in the tax filing date from April
to July 15th so with no revenue coming
in because of that federal decision will
have to potentially borrow resources to
bridge that gap temporarily those
revenues should come in that's different
than the revenue actual shortfall which
is a result of having only essential
businesses open and that revenue not
coming in but to bridge that gap will do
short-term borrowing we still have a ten
billion dollar revenue shortfall but the
essential problem on the budget is who
were clears when you have that big a
hole that has to be closed there's two
things you can do you can sort of paper
over it and come up with expectations
well we believe the next federal bill
will actually deliver money to the state
of New York yeah you could say that and
you could say I believe that Santa Claus
is real you know but I'm not comfortable
doing that especially since the federal
government just passed the bill and
that's what we were just hoping for
and the federal government just did the
exact opposite and handed us a goose egg
well we expect the economy is going to
rebound in nine months and that it's
going to be what they call the V curve
it was a quick down it's gonna be a
quick up and in nine months all those
revenues are gonna keep come flooding
back so we're gonna be fine that's
another way of papering over the whole I
don't want to do that either because I
don't believe it and I don't believe
anyone's gonna believe it and I don't
believe credit agencies are gonna
believe it and I believe postponing a
problem in government in life you just
make it worse you just make it worse
let's not deceive ourselves you're not
gonna get saved by the federal
government if they were going to do it
they would have done it
they played their own politics shocker
this is not going to be a quick down
quick up you're looking at weeks or
months and I don't know how quick the
recovery and the recovery is going to be
complicated and everybody says it so I'm
not going to say to the people of this
state there is a theory of economics
that I don't believe I believe we have
to actually deal with the numbers that
are presented by the way like every
family in this state has to deal with
the numbers everybody's income is down
and they don't get to make up numbers or
make up a rationale well I'm going to go
buy a new car because I think I'm going
to get rehired and I think I'm gonna get
rehired at a job that pays more so I'm
gonna go buy a new car I'm not the weird
I'm not doing it they can't do it I'm
not gonna do it it's gonna be honest I
know it's politically hard for the
legislature I know that you know
legislative bodies they want to make
friends by giving out a lot of money
we've been successful in being very
prudent economically our spending rate
has gone up less than any Administration
in modern history our budgets have
passed and they've been right
I'm not going to change that now so I'm
not going to paper over the economic
reality and I know it's difficult for
them but I'm not gonna do it
otherwise I can tell you that right now
I'm not gonna pass or sign a phony
budget the same policy issues we've been
discussing all along the main policy
objections they object to a policy
proposal that I put in which would be a
bill that is meant to fight against
anti-semitism anti-semitism has been a
major problem in this state you know
right now we have coronavirus and that
sort of eclipses everything we tend to
be myopic we've had dozens and dozens of
anti-semitic attacks all across this
state I've been there with families who
have been attacked I was there the
morning after the first night of
Hanukkah when a rabbis home was attacked
not to address anti-semitism in the
state I think is a terrible mistake and
it's not just anti-semitism it's what I
call domestic terrorism it's repugnant
to the concept of New York and America
to attack someone based on their race
color creed if you try to kill someone
if you kill someone in in an attempt to
kill several people based on their race
color or creed how is that not a
terrorist act you kill someone and you
were attempting to kill multiple people
based on the race color creed they don't
want to pass that bill and this
objections to the surrogacy bill which
would allow which would help infertile
women who can't have a child can't carry
a child biologically from having a
surrogate so they can have a child it
would stop LGBTQ couples from having a
child which is wholly ironic to me
this is the state that first passed
marriage equality now you say to that
couple who you said you can get married
but you can't have a family and you can
because you can't have a child makes no
sense to me but those are the main
discussions let's go to work guys
I have to go thank you